Ladies and gentlemen,...
...I'm not sure whether this is appropriate in this very solemn ceremony to say a few words of my personal reflection.
People say that good things come to those who wait.
And I know that is true.
And I will tell you why.
Almost 40 years ago, when President Nixon of the United States...
...had established a diplomatic relationship with the People's Republic of China.
There was a high expectation in the United States...
...about how to improve their relationship with the People's Republic of China...
...and they might have wanted to have some perspectives of an Asian person.
I was a young, very junior foreign ministry official at that time,...
...and I learned that one of the most prestigious universities in the United States...
...was sponsoring a full-ride scholarship for a student from my part of the world for Chinese studies.
It was the University of Washington.
And I leapt at the chance.
So, I studied and worked hard, and I took extra exams,...
...and I put everything into it.
And one day, a letter arrived.
I was selected for an interview.
I was so excited.
And I was invited to come to a certain place called the Royal Hotel in Seoul.
I was sure that I would get that.
When I went to the Royal Hotel,...
...I was surprised to find just a dozen of Korean citizens,...